bene a tutti ragazzi per questo nuovo
video che sono parigi oggi siamo qua
davanti a questa spada gigante che non è
realtà importante del never solo con me
ciao a ecco stai facendo entrata tipo le
veline a striscia la notizia golino e
marcon davanti a guardare dalle veline
ma la cosa no cosa che mi piace un sacco
e che io c'ero anch'io l'armatura
pensavo di essere messo molto peggio ma
non ho lo scudo vabbè ma gara questo
hanno rubato in realtà non è mio bene
poi non fare un altro tavolo riprende di
tanto non è mica grazie alla di regalo
grazie ma io sono stato già avanti
rispetto a voi chirikova per il ragazzo
un'oscura enel tenuto un altro
ecco qua mi piace come attaccherà
aspetta proviamo forse avendo ucciso
fuori non lo attaccano
abbiamo apriamo alla rivista per e che
sono pacifici ma se ne mattina loro
poetica e credo che non conosce la sai
[Musica]
beh certezza fortissima i ragazzi quello
dell'iran o io beh ragazzi spero che un
accendino sei un grande pensate che come
faceva torna dietro da un po
dovevamo scambiare con i figli che ci
davano la cosa caricata se la rai vieni
qua che dobbiamo capire se sono
arrabbiati con te subito no no no
comunque da quello che quello che rimane
del fight club non si dice meno male che
belli iniziale sia statali morale
all'inizio no no no no no siamo partiti
benissimo lo vedeva di continuare
ragazzo che conosco niente visto mondo
ma niente perché guarda perché fa
tomasson bellissima mi salvo le cose che
ci perderemo sicuramente ovviamente
cento per cento
adesso però io ti seguo non voglio farti
da barzagli in discorso è che non sono
ammazzati dove stiamo andando
ok che noi ora il problema per chi non
sono molto molto esperto di meter quindi
non so per che cosa puoi trovare di
roberto no sei morto raga occhio che ho
creato un ponte sono arrivati alla
foresta ecco a voi siete già qui avete
fatto che vi siete portati sopra ma dare
e gli alberi della foresta come sono
diritti e materiali sono non c'ero io
quando c'erano queste cose è un dopo
legno promesso da poco comunque ed è
molto bello ma tiene solo rubando un
pochino perché bellissimo
po di margine colpito mi hanno colpito
viene mai ci sono davanti davanti lo
ammazzo io dico come padalino sammarco
non è bravo ma sei katniss everdeen 6
formalissimo bravissimi una cosa vedi
che queste persone tecnicamente foglia
girati guarda vedi queste qua in alto
aiuterai a come si spaccano le foglie a
mano noi saperla zappa guarda la zappa
il pianeta regalerà me prendere una
fidanzata tappa di metallo a cosa ti
serve è per spaccare questi velocemente
ma bellissimi con blocchi da costruttore
e bellini al per i rossi più avanti
la madonna mi stavi anche il tappeto lo
so qui mi sono cagato nelle mutande
ho sentito bossi terribile la scena è
brutta si aspetta allora cosa cioè sì sì
sì qua si estende tutto ok 94 non lo
vedono qui sono qui vi insegni una cosa
rete è il cui obiettivo è la per terra
che sono giunte è soli c'è il cinghiale
in realtà è uscito da una dovrebbero
esserci anche i peeling quelli se non
avete almeno un pezzo di armatura in oro
o qualcosa in oro in mano vi attaccano
ok perfetto
sono morto beh mi ha preso la mia presa
di peso che fa esatto guardateve di
questi qua dietro di te a questi quasi
ok avete almeno un pezzo di armatori
erano allora che a spina finalmente è
tornato utile loro in minecraft esatto
non serviva a niente per via del gol da
all reja
ok ecco il dr dovremmo vedere quelle pp
tela e poi fare blocco
vedo che la società kcal ecco come non
pensavo anche l'occhio chiamano fuori
sempre schifoso maledetto che brutti che
siano forze che vogliono
e che vogliono perché praticamene se tu
ti butti poi dell'oro loro ti danno un
oggetto casuale per averne libia se
l'inflazione ci stanno ragione di
emulazione sono i bancari
questo mio ma è bellissimo razzi chi
sperava che lo faranno in più li vede
benissimo quando tali manca sembra che
palin in opera d'arte
no sono amici non sono morti invece non
sono morto perché sono una persona
intelligente ogni tanto brutale minori
dell'aquila come facciamo e per l'acqua
aiuto aiuto io sono morto mangiandola
già cominciato da un ora ho mangiato ok
sono vivo per miracolo
banche poste assistiamo è questo qui è
un bel via ma per i blocchi ma non tanto
per per vivere
venite e vedete che lasci un altro sorta
di blocco nero con l'aria la pietra
nyala plextor bellissimo ah ecco quella
che sto prende adesso esatto per ha
visto e questo è veramente bella in
effetti era attento ce la fai
toni sveglio lo facciamo fare lui mangia
abbia mangiato abbia mangiato dai dai
peccato che peccato ma dai slate è
stranissimo kgb odio che tra tagli e si
scende
sono scesa dall altra parte non c'è
nulla che rovaris parma stanno lottando
o si occhio vi sono mi hanno caricato di
brutto ma non mi hanno fatto niente mi
sono pagato
cosa è successo anch'io sento qui ci
sorprendiamo penso di sì prendiamo sane
sono niente opposta vita
vai prendete il caso lo prendo io e te
lo do che vai march periodo ma che
stimolano schifo fanno dei rumori si
sale per la mattina ciao ciao a piacere
i nostri migranti bisogna risalire
lorenzo italiano vabbè ce l'hanno
blocchi ore poi c'è qualcosa progetta e
si ingerendola motorola delle ceste
giusto lampadario lo staff in casa
scusate che la catena di tutta la
bagarre e quindi è gratis
io vi so dire poi variabili vista
sappiate come quando vedi che prendeva i
tempi amici come state siamo molto bello
andarci lui e non io
madonna e dobbiamo trovare certo io non
ho mai trovato un basso requisita questo
non c'era più di tanto quindi buoni ma
adatto anche non ci sono mai stato
troppo hanno caricato e non qualcosa si
è fatto qualcosa io ho un canto lo
levino metodo ma c'è se non su 26 e stef
e morto prendono solo
ho rubato la lampada si è arrabbiato ai
a hamadan era solo l'oro qualsiasi sono
davvero prima ma ho trovato spendere 98
l'ho accantonato 16 che ho tratto una
cesta guarda che cacchio è 26 sono
trovato così eccoci ieri ieri mi sta
barricando guarda mi sono accorto preso
io la voglio arrivarci no per loro che
hanno aiutato tutta la roba ma ci arrivo
aspetto arrivo tanto è bastato vicino in
teoria allora amici il problema non è
questo prima che succeda che è venuto
anzi attaccherà non solo me perché ora
esatto noi siamo morti
quindi divertiamo facciamoci una scala
noi perché voglio guarda la quadra
quadro che poi di sicuro ci sono anche
altre chest quindi vediamo di muoverci
giocare anche qua ci sente veramente
brutta io vorrei
pensavo di essere con voi mi girano 3
maiali madonna pavi girati liquidata
cosa cioè cielo stryder creditizio prima
con la sella che stanno andando bene
morto è morto
occhio che mi attacca questo aiuto a
questo tipo un guardiano tutti noi uno è
morto
2 abbiamo tutte le somme la ski promo ha
trovato un aces devastante secondo lo
zio di quello in diamante con fortuna 1
posto male hai trovato
non ci tornate le sei io non sono anche
non so anche tutti sono in cima al
fortuny veri ma io vedo marci
perché come ci sei arrivato lì e allora
ho trovato un cinghiale che mi ha
attaccato ma e cinghiale vero quello
gigantesco ho avuto in combattimento
epico qui sopra assieme al cinghiale
gigantesco vinto e terrà la festa
bellissima devo dare la carne di
cinghiale che vorrei infine se possibile
non dicono e quindi è finita e pieni
tieniti regala una palette grazie una
palestra ma non sarà mai finito ragazzi
ora te quante cronaca le trecce però che
hanno fatto se non fai da te perché
siccome ci sono altre chester lo sto
arrivando sono stati da me non so come
diavolo posso fare perché ti sto
scavando sotto i piedi però si guarda e
ti giuro non ha una cosa del genere
aprica madonna ci sono delle palline
magiche che tiri no una cosa più
importante quel coso milan siete dei
compagni di classe come le mans in
thebris praticamente è il miglior alle
più raro del gioco pratica minerale
virale non ho mai sia praticamente se tu
loquaci ti da un oggetto che si chiama
ne dirige scrap se ne trovi quattro
linee diritte scrap elemetti 4 nella
crafting con loro vuoi farci il
linguaggio di eder idriche e serve per
trattare le armature più forti del gioco
però ci sono un miliardo e mezzo di
passaggi vanno capite lo so hai ragione
sembrava wikihow madonna non ho capito
più niente march how marcia
complimenti per sapere tutto di tutti i
ragazzi line castigatissimo ragazzi io
ho paura non uscirei tale intesa ma non
durante
6 come sei dove sei come sei
allora mi vedete in qualche modo agli
amici attorno ai a nostra vivo mi ha
spinto misure l'embargo mi ha spinto lui
in un posto dove non mi può raggiungere
e un bar è morto stefano vedo lei lo
stesso e così ci sono otto è ovvio una
spiegati non amano e morto riprende un
aziende briscoe sma generis che non ho
mai capito cos'è però ti fa fare
l'animatore di forti del gioco e questa
cosa la so perché mica me l'ha detta
marci ok è andato senza prenderlo queste
razze amico mio grazie ai centri non
sono anche con gente hybrid hybris
possiamo andar via la signora ma come
andiamo via da come saranno di 556.000
pagava le lasciamo italia.it è tanta
roba che vogliono non mi stare anche più
neanche se trovo qualcosa di vita
alimentare
andiamo via via via a me le diamo via
via torniamo a casa come ai box
vi prego pazzesco non voglio più avere
niente a che fare questo ma via via via
via v
chiari ha invidiato ciò è stato lì ma
quella partenza è terribile l'altro una
mamma io ho perso tutto quello che avevo
addosso disastro battagliero veramente
capito comunque l'importante ragazzi
essere arrivati con questi ance dove
cacchio accende brees va bene ragazzi io
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto è
stato divertente
abbiamo registrato un sacco portogallo
dio palma è stato un casino legata
all'idea
spero che vi do vi sia piaciuto cosa
devo giorno mentre che non sarà anche la
casa di steve march descrizione e noi ci
vediamo sempre tacchi alti
beh ragazzi
[Musica]
ma